[Music]
why don't we speak next to
oh i don't know why don't we go to our
friend bitdefender from cancun
bitdefender welcome
hello
hello yes
hey dude i was listening to
an episode of yours earlier this week
with mr coleman hughes
um
and you may you mentioned this idea in
which people have to play dirty to
move forward you know how um
in certain circumstances we have to bend
or break the rules yeah i did
to be clear
what i what i said was
there are people who argue that to
achieve real change you have to play
dirty and break rules i wasn't
necessarily asserting at myself on any
particular issue but i was proposing it
as a thought element for the
conversation
yes exactly and i know you don't
necessarily espouse that idea okay um
and and i wanted to expand a little bit
on on why you wouldn't want to expose
that because i don't think you mentioned
it in depth in that segment um but
ultimately all boils down to it is
precisely this attitude which allows
you know well well we may say well we're
doing some menial evil for a greater
good um the same logic it gets perverted
to
you know defend
a greater good for myself
in exchange for a
greater hurt for the rest of the world i
guess you know let me see if i
understand what you're saying let me see
if i can summarize what you're saying
you're saying the problem with
justifying breaking rules or laws in
order to achieve a particular outcome if
you evaluate that the outcome is
worthwhile
is that once you open that door next
thing you know you're saying well maybe
murder is okay to justify a good outcome
or maybe
raping and pillaging of an entire
village or whatever you're saying that
it's a slippery slope of sorts once we
say well you can decide whether these
are laws that should be broken to
achieve a goal
you've kind of entered an area that
lends itself to all sorts of different
justifications
yes that's exactly right and the the
problem is
precisely more than the sleeper slope
argument uh it's it's more of a well
they are willing to play the long game
and take tiny steps to achieve those
goals while we are usually
you know we have a mind of
we need to make big changes for the
world to be a better place
that's an interesting idea yeah i mean
the problem is that there really are
sometimes laws that are unjust and i'm
not talking about murder right but there
are sometimes laws that are unjust when
it comes to protesting or uh being heard
in different ways that that sort of that
type of thing um so i think that that's
that's the difficulty of it bitdefender
i have to ask where are you calling from
because not only are you echoey there
was like a speaker phone announcement a
couple minutes ago
i i'm so sorry it's uh just part of the
job
in a police station you know oh you're
in a position station wow wow yeah i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'll have to visit next
time next time i'm in cancun i'll have
to visit the police station and see what
you're up to
the
the tourism police station particularly
tourism you're free to come any time
beautiful all right bitdefender thank
you for the call
thank you david all right there's
bitdefender from mexico always great to
hear from him